[MUSIC PLAYING]
BOB MEESE: Good
morning, everyone.
My name is Bob Meese.
As Tod said, I'm the head of
games business development
for Google Play.
And I'm here to
talk to you today
about running a successful
games business with Google.
I'll primarily talk about
two different things--
so talking about the various
Google services that we believe
are most helpful
to game developers
in building your business.
And then I'll also highlight
some of the best practices
from the various developers
in the ecosystem.
And I want to thank the
developers that helped
me put together that material.
So let's begin.
And first you'll see some of the
slides that many of us present.
Greg presented this too.
But there's a couple
reasons why you'll
see these over and over again.
And one is because they're
very important metrics that
lay the foundation
for the platform,
and also because we're
very proud of some
of these accomplishments
of the platform
overall that we've achieved
with all of your help.
But first, you should
all know that Android
is a very big platform.
There's more than 1 billion
monthly active Android users
globally now, which creates a
huge opportunity for everyone.
As we've said, more than
three in four of those people
are playing games.
And so when you combine
those two facts,
you have a huge user base--
many of whom are playing games.
That's the largest
group of people playing
games on any platform ever.
And then finally what that
translates then to you--
last week we announced
that we had paid out
more than $7 billion to
developers over the past 12
months.
So there's a very clear
commercial opportunity
for developers today.
And that number keeps
rising and rising.
And so in terms of the
main agenda for today,
I first want to share a few
tips on working with all of us.
Then I want to talk
about recommendations
that we have across the life
cycle of all of your games,
from development to
operation of all your games.
So first working with us--
here's the team we're growing.
So if I had shown you this
slide three years ago,
it would have been just
Yoshiko and myself.
It was just the three of us.
But now here's the team.
A couple of key points to
mention in the Bay Area here.
Mountain View would've been
hiring some world-class game
experts in APAC.
What started with just
an office in Japan
has now expanded into Korea
and Taiwan in Southeast Asia.
And Europe-- we're growing
the team there as well.
Unfortunately, Mobile World
Congress is this week as well.
But Adema is still here
to join us from Russia.
And then we should note that
we hired Regina late last year
as our head for Latin America.
And we've recently expanded
to a new continent.
And so the key message here
is that wherever you are,
we're hiring people and
building teams to support you.
And I also want to talk
about expanding our developer
support as well, too,
because hiring people is not
the end goal.
It's important that we
improve our online tools
because email and
LinkedIn inboxes can't
be the final answer to this.
for us, I know that it's hard
to manage that overall process.
And so I want
everybody to know here
that we're investing in
our online tools that
help us further qualify new
developers that we work with.
And so if you go to this
short link right here,
you can fill out a
short form that'll
help us better work
with all of you.
And the key point
here is that we're
investing in improving
the overall communication
channels between Google
and the developer community
because we really do care
about everyone's success.
In terms of the life
cycle of game development
in the various Google
services and best practices,
first I want to start
with pre-launch.
And so pre-launch is you're
about to launch your game.
You haven't yet
launched your game.
You hopefully have this
mountain of traffic
that's about to come your way.
And game launches are
getting bigger and bigger.
And at this moment,
you really want
to make sure that you've
tested your game fully
so that if you're
lucky enough to get hit
by this mountain
of traffic, that's
a positive experience that
doesn't crush your game.
And we will note that
the game launches
are becoming bigger and bigger.
They're in some cases even being
compared to Hollywood movies.
I was talking to
Wooga recently, who
launched a big game last week.
And they'll be featured
later on in the presentation.
It was the first game that
they had launched in 18 months.
They actually spent 18
months developing this game,
but they had talked about
all of the activity that
was going into it.
They invested all that time.
And now that it was launching,
they had a big budget.
They had a big press outreach
plan that was happening.
And they said 18
months ago when they
had launched their
previous game,
all they did was publish the
game and issue a press release.
And so we definitely see
these launches changing--
becoming bigger and bigger.
And so in that environment
it's even more important
that developers are doing proper
beta testing for the games.
And so in this case we do
offer Google Play beta testing
as a key offering.
It's been around for a while.
But it's very important to us.
We want to encourage as
many developers as possible
to use it.
And so in terms of some of
the basics of that service,
it is a private, invite-only
beta testing group
that helps you all work on play
testing and technical readiness
of your games.
We really focus on the
communication channels
that we both enable and
disable during this process.
And so it's important to know
that ratings and reviews don't
exist during this time.
It's not appropriate
during the beta test period
that people be able to publicly
rate and review their game.
And so that's impossible.
However, we really do
optimize the channel
between the beta testers
and the developer itself.
This is all enabled
through Google Groups.
And we really focus on having as
much communication as possible
between testers and developers.
And then we should note that
two tracks are available.
And so we have both an alpha
and a beta testing track
in case developers
wanted to have
multiple versions of their games
being tested at the same time.
So as I mentioned, this service
has been around for a while.
We want more
developers using it.
We're seeing some developers
like Matt and Ralph
from Vector Unit that have
Google Play beta testing
as a standard part
of their workflow.
And we want to see more and
more developers have this state.
They're also nice
enough to-- in November,
they wrote a blog
post for GammaSutra
that provided a lot of
detail on their experience
with Google Play beta testing.
So I encourage all of
you to go check that out.
In terms of this summary
in a quick slide,
they encouraged a
lot of developers
to think about a couple of
different things-- one of which
was really choosing
your audience wisely.
And so in their
case, I mentioned
they did both an alpha
and a beta channel.
But they found that the beta
channel was much more popular
just because the game was
more stable in that channel.
And so in their case
in the alpha channel,
it was a more unstable process.
And so their friends
and family were
very happy to use that version.
But they noticed that the
vast majority of players
were on the beta channel.
Also, setting expectations
early is very important.
And so there it is important to
know that your beta testers are
using software that can
be unstable in some cases.
And so it's important
to lay that foundation.
Also, it's very
important that you
let people know that
you really want feedback
during this process.
And so being very
clear, the part
of the exchange
on the players is
to provide as much clear and
detailed feedback as possible.
And then, finally, this
beta testing process
is all about feedback.
And so encouraging as
much feedback as possible
is really the goal.
Here there are things that
you can do as a developer
to help enable it as well too.
And so within the forms, if you
can reply very quickly to posts
to help your
community feel alive.
Matt and Ralph found that was
really valuable-- and even
going so far as to
thank those people that
are leaving critical
feedback, as long as it's
constructive and
detailed and clear,
because that's really what you
want out of this whole process.
Next I'll talk about
pre-registration.
And so as I talked
about with beta testing,
there's going to be
a group of people
who want to play your game
no matter what state it's in.
But pre-registration is
largely about that next group
of people-- the fans that
want to play your game as
soon as it's publicly launched.
And so the basic part
of pre-registration
is a way for you to notify
the fans of your games
when your game first
becomes available.
And also our APAC team
has been telling us
about pre-registration
for a while.
It's a practice that's
very popular in leading
markets like Korea and Japan.
And we believe that it is a
practice that will increasingly
be popular worldwide.
Here are a few examples
in Korea and Japan.
On your left, there's an example
of a small Korean developer.
In case your Korean
is not as good
as those who are in Korea,
what's being offered here
is there's an offer of about
$10 of in-app items for free
for anybody who pre-registers
the game before launch.
This game is about
to launch very soon.
And this small
developer has already
registered 10,000
people for the game.
And so for a small developer to
have that momentum for launch,
it's a big advantage
versus someone
who hasn't gone
through this process.
And then on your
left, you'll see
Konami, who's a very
successful Japanese developer.
And this is an example of
pre-registration for their game
"Power Pro Baseball."
And you might see
on the bottom here,
you can see one,
three, five, and ten.
And so these are
different tiers or targets
to pre-register, in total,
10,000, 30,000, 50,000,
and 100,000 people.
And if those goals
are met, you can also
see a cascade of
various in-app items.
And if those goals are met, all
of the pre-registered players
will receive those
items at launch.
And so this creates
a referral system
that encourages pre-registered
players to go get their friends
to also pre-register.
And so that's one of the
more intermediate systems
within pre-registration.
And so this is a quick recap.
Pre-regristration-- so
the basic functionality
is notifying your fans
that the game has launched
and offering them
some type of reward.
A more intermediate system is
introducing referral systems
so that people
have an opportunity
to invite others and spread
the word for your game.
And then, finally, there's
even some more advanced systems
where they have
interactive events
with Japanese
developers, including
gotcha mechanics in the games
that allow players to win
rare items in the game,
so they have an advantage
even before the game launches.
Next I want to talk
about user acquisition.
Here there's many things
that developers are doing.
But we bear some of the
responsibility as well.
And so when we think about
the Play Store listing page,
we did a nice redesign last
year basically adopting
the material design principles
within the Play Store itself.
You can see "Leo's
Fortune" pictured both
on the left and the right--
the left before the redesign
and then the right
after material redesign.
And what you'll
notice is that there's
several of the elements on
the page that are really
helpful to learn more about the
game that are brought to life.
And so here on the
right, the video
that's featured right
there at the top.
And then, also, the
short description
at the bottom that's
above the fold
is very visible as
well, too, is really
called out in more
prominence in the new design.
So going into a bit more
detail on the listing pages,
the icon, as many developers
know, is very important.
You put a lot of time and
effort into your game.
It's important that
your icon reflect
the quality of your
game and the creativity
and the personality
of the game as well.
And with Leopold here, I
think that this developer's
done a great job.
On the right here
with the description
it is important to
quickly communicate
the value of the game
to your audience.
And so here I'm
adventuring through
a gorgeous, handcrafted world
to recover your stolen gold.
It sounds pretty good to me.
I think the developer
has used that space well.
On the bottom here, video,
as we were talking about,
is very important.
It's the best way to
capture the attention
of your potential audience.
And then to
complement the video,
we have screenshots
on the right here.
In these screenshots,
you can do other things
like layering on text here.
So in this case, the
developer's really
focusing on some of the
critical acclaim and the awards
that they've won.
So we find that to
be very valuable.
Next, I want to talk about a
best practice of A/B testing
icon design before
your game goes live.
And so here, this
is an example of Glu
and their game
"Deer Hunter 2014."
And so in this case, they
had all these different ideas
and permutations on what
their icon could look like.
They really wanted to make
sure that they were converting
as many people as possible
from the store listing page
and just the people who had
viewed the icon down to those
who installed the game.
And so through that
process-- through A/B testing
of the various icon
types-- they ended up
with the version of
the icon at right.
And you'll notice if you
check out the game now,
this A/B testing continues
through launch as well.
They have a fully
different version
of the icon than any of these
right now in the game too.
And so being very thoughtful
about your icon in A/B
testing it and optimizing for
conversion is quite important.
Next, I'll keep it
short and sweet.
But we encourage you
as a best practice
to keep your file sizes small.
We notice a clear
correlation between the games
that have smaller
file sizes and those
that get the most installs.
And so please, if possible, try
to keep your games below the 50
megabyte OTA limit.
Next, I'll talk about the Google
Play referral flow report.
And this is something where
developers often ask us.
They say, I would love
to know more about what
is happening during
the conversion
funnel in the Play Store.
I'd love to know how many
impressions I'm getting
and how that's
converting to installs.
Some developers don't know
that's actually available now.
And so what you need
to do to do that is you
connect your Google
Analytics account
to your Google Play
Developer Console account.
And by doing that,
you can get data
about the number of
impressions that you're
getting to your Play
Store listing page,
the number of installs
you're getting
from Play-- the number of opens
that you're getting from that.
So it's a valuable
source of data
that I don't think enough
developers know about.
And so I wanted to
highlight that here today.
Also.
it's very exciting.
I made an announcement last week
about sponsored search results
and Google Play.
It's a pilot that we'll roll
out in the next few weeks.
And so I should note that it's
still a very early stage pilot.
We don't have a timetable
for greater roll out.
But over the long
term, it is a project
that we're very excited about.
And then finally
in this section,
video as I've talked about
is a very engaging medium.
YouTube is obviously a great
source of video content.
And so here we see
developers saying
that video is working
for them in general
and that Machine Zone
has gone a step further.
And they said that the players
that they are acquiring
through YouTube are higher-value
players than any other video
platform.
And so it's something that
the developer should certainly
be looking at.
That's it for the user
acquisition section.
Next up is engagement retention.
And so here I had
mentioned Wooga earlier.
But they're really an
example of the best practice
of frequent content updates
to help engage and retain
your players.
And so this is Jens here
saying, "Like the best
TV, in 'Agent Alice' we deliver
a new episode every week."
They have really found
that investing in story
is really important for
them-- that the narrative
of their previous games has
been one of the elements
that their core players
and their target audience
really enjoys about the game.
And so it builds up a sense of
expectations and anticipation
that keeps players coming back
over a very long time period.
And that's the goal.
And so just a quick, one-slide
overview of Wooga's most
recent game, "Agent Alice."
And so here you can
see on the upper-left,
as Jens mentioned, they take
a TV series approach where
a new episode of the game
is available every Thursday.
They keep players coming back
and expecting that new episode.
On the upper-right, you can
see that the developer layers
on a variety of
different length arcs.
And so you have the
core weekly arc that's
built around the episode.
But then you have the
mid-arcs of the games.
And so you have Agent Alice
Wallace and all of her friends
and all of the various
things that they're
doing in the game that keeps
people engaged over a longer
time.
And then, finally, you have
the main arc of the game.
And so Wooga is building this
game and staff and the content
production of it
to last over years.
And so it's really
important that there's
a way to connect that basic
weekly cycle with a much
longer time horizon.
Of course, I should note
that investing in content
like this is not cheap.
And so here Wooga is investing
20 person hours a week
into content production.
So while this is a very
effective strategy,
it comes at an expense.
But what that provides a very
rich character set in the game.
And so they have more
than 100 characters
already in the game at launch
with three new characters
coming every week.
So I think this example
of Wooga's "Agent Alice"
is a great example of frequent
content updates as a way
to engage and
entertain your players.
Next I want to talk about
Google Play Games or our games
network, which is
growing very rapidly.
One of things that
we're excited to see
is that Google Play games is
becoming an essential part
of more developer's games.
More developers are adopting
the services overall.
And that's helped fuel
the overall growth.
And one of the
things that we see
is that signed-in
players are consistently
more valuable than other players
within developer's games.
And as Ben and others
have talked about before,
we're investing into adding
more and more services on top
of the core of Google
Play Games to make
the services increasingly
valuable over time.
So here is Oliver from
Hothead Games saying
that Google Play Games have
become an essential part
of their games.
And when you think
about why that is,
here's one of their games,
"Rivals at War-- Firefight."
And they point out that sign-in
players have 30% greater
playtime per player and 2.3x
greater premium currency spent
per DAU.
And when you're seeing
results like this,
that really helps people
understand that there's value
in implementing these services.
Also, I'd like to do a quick
recap of player analytics.
It's something where
Ben presented it now
and John Burge will actually
give a lightning talk on it
in a little bit.
But it's something we're
very excited about.
I want to go into
a bit more detail.
And so as we talk about,
there's managing targets.
And so what happens here is that
you're setting revenue goals
and you have a
daily feedback loop
to be able to check your
progress against those targets.
You can identify hotspots.
And so we help you compare
your game to similar games
and identify areas where your
game is doing particularly well
and areas where
you have some gaps.
And then, finally,
understanding your players
and so getting a
better sense for when
people are leaving
your game and where
people are leaving your game.
And so here the core of player
analytics is a set of reports.
And so as we showed here,
managing your targets
with the business
drivers dashboard,
identifying your hotspots with
the business drivers report,
and understanding your
players with the retention
table in the player
progression report.
So as I said, we'll go
into more detail on that.
But it's something
where it's early,
but we're very excited
about the potential here.
Within managing targets,
you set a revenue goal.
You can check daily progress.
If you're exceeding your
goals, which is great,
then you may even
consider raising them.
But if you're not
hitting your goals,
then you want to
look for hotspots.
And that's where we move
into identifying hotspots.
And so here one of the key
benefits of player analytics
is comparing your game to
similar games across a variety
of different cohorts
of players who
have been in the game for
various amounts of time
and across various key
metrics like engagement
and monetization--
and there being
able to drill down for each
of these different cells that
are there-- each state
is in one of five states.
So from deep red if you're
underperforming to deep green
if you're overperforming.
And so we provide
you with a quick way
to visualize your relative
performance in your segment.
And then finally looking
at understanding players.
So having the retention
table to understand
when your players are leaving
the game-- how long they
are sticking around.
And then the player
progression report
to understand how many
achievements players are
completing before
they're leaving the game.
And so as I said,
this is something
that we're very excited about.
And we encourage everybody
to look into player analytics
when it's available
in a few weeks.
Next thing I want to talk
about-- monetization.
And so here, like I said,
it's an important number
that we're very proud
of that last week we
announced that we
paid out $7 billion
to developers over
the past 12 months.
One of things that
has fueled that growth
has been our investment
in the payments platform.
And so here, as we
mentioned, we're
investing in relationships
with direct carrier billing,
expanding our gift card
support, and introducing
Paypal in the last year.
Just a bit more
detail on that too.
So direct carrier billing
is now available in 32
different countries.
And one thing to note there
is that since about the middle
of last year we really
focused on where
are the regions where we most
need direct carrier billing?
And so since the
middle of last year,
we've turned on a half dozen
countries in Southeast Asia
to help improve the
monetization of that region.
In the case of Google
Play gift cards,
they are now available in
28 different countries.
If you're not
following this closely
as some of the people on
that team, at this time
last year, only seven countries
had Google Play gift cards.
And so in the course
of one year, there's
been a 4x increase in the
number of countries that are
Google Play gift card enabled.
And so that's feeling big
advantages and improvements
in the overall
payments platform.
And then, finally, Paypal
which only became available
in the last year is
now available in 19
different countries focused
on the parts of the world
where Paypal is most popular,
including Western Europe
and North America.
Next I want to talk
about premium games.
So as you can see from
the top grossing charts,
in our purchased games,
free-to-play games
are driving most of
the top grossing.
But that does not mean that
it's the only thing that
succeeds on the platform.
And so for us, you look
at what are the games that
are most successful right now.
And you have "Minecraft."
You have "Trivia Crack"--
the paid version--
and you have "Five
Nights at Freddy's."
And those are three examples
of recently successful premium
games.
What we believe is that even
if this category of games
is not the major driver
of platform revenue,
we really do believe
that there are
many developers out there that
love creating premium games.
And we believe that
there are many players
in the platform that love
playing premium games.
And so it's important
for us that this category
continue to exist and do well.
And so I just wanted to leave
you with those two things
that if you're
making premium games,
we believe that the
category is important.
And so know that.
But also know that if
you look at the trends,
even if you look at "Minecraft"
in its top grossing rank,
it has declined over
the last year or so.
So just recognize that the
overall trend in monetization
is not with you,
but that we want
to find ways to support a very
healthy ecosystem measured
a bunch of different
ways and that includes
premium games being
successful in the platform.
Furthering the story
on monetization,
I next want to talk about ads.
And so here we want developers
to have the flexibility
to monetize through
in-app purchase,
through upfront payments
in premium games,
and also through advertising.
Here we'll call out that AdMob
is the largest mobile ads
platform in the world with
more than 650,000 app and game
developers monetizing
with AdMob every month,
including some of the
notable game developers
at the bottom of the page here.
And so clearly there's this
great momentum behind AdMob.
Talking about how
developers earn with AdMob
and some of the momentum.
And so we're seeing
growth in CPMs
over time, which is a
great sign of the health
of that ecosystem.
And the developers are
earning significant money
with ads as well with
more than $1 billion
being paid out over
the last two years.
Also, we're investing in
making it easier for all of you
to get AdMob into
your games, including
the creation of plug-ins getting
into game engines like Unity
and Cocos2d-x.
Next I want to talk about
international-- a very
important topic when you think
about those billions of devices
that are out there with
Android, many of them
are obviously not
in this country.
And so developers
ask us what are
the most important countries?
What are the countries
that are growing
that I should be targeting.
And here's a couple of
different categories.
So developers may be familiar
with the largest revenue
markets, but maybe not as
much with those countries
where you have the largest
install base or the fastest
growing install bases.
And so the countries in
those latter two categories
of large install
bases-- fastest growing
install bases-- are countries
like Mexico and Brazil
and Turkey,
Indonesia, and Russia.
So if you're not targeting
those countries today,
we encourage you to do so.
We're seeing a great
amount of growth there.
And really when I talk
about how developers
start to expand
internationally, I
was having a really good
conversation with a leading
developer on Friday.
And they talked about
how they had expanded
their international strategy
over time where it was really
a three-step process.
At first they were just
focused on succeeding
in their domestic market.
And they felt they were doing
a good enough job there.
And so then they started
to expand internationally.
But the second
stage for them was
going international where it
was kind of an even approach
everywhere.
And that's not something that
can always be successful.
Some games are
lucky enough to be
able to address all
international audiences fairly
evenly, but this developer was
calling out the third stage
that they were at
right now as targeting
international
audiences, but really
thinking very specifically
about each one-- the way
that their games should
be different in Brazil
versus Russia, for example,
because those audiences are
obviously different.
And they want and deserve
different content.
And so with that I'll go
into a bit more detail.
It's always interesting
to look across the world
about the games that are
popular on Google Play
and start to assess how you
might think about your games
and which markets are relevant
for you given your game.
But in the United States-- we
see a great amount of diversity
still in the United States
with games from casual games
to strategy games to
social casino games
to action RPGs-- from developers
all across the world--
European developers, US-based
developers, developers
in Israel-- developers in Asia.
So we certainly believe that
success in the United States
is still a goal for many
different developers.
So that's part of what
fuels the diversity
and the greatness
of the content here
is that developers
from all over the world
are trying to be successful
in the United States.
Next, if you look at
Google Play in Japan,
you'll notice "Monster
Strike" and "Puzzle & Dragons"
have been doing very, very
well there for awhile.
And so you'll learn that
the Japanese love dragons.
But then you'll also notice
that combining different game
systems is actually
quite important.
So with "Puzzle & Dragons,"
taking a puzzle game and adding
RPG elements is
really significant.
With "Monster Strike,"
taking an RPG and adding
slingshot mechanics is
their path to success.
So more complex gaming
systems that are combined
has been quite popular
in Japan for some time.
One thing we will note too
is Japan really stands out
for being a relatively
tough market
for international
developers to crack.
If you look here, you're seeing
a whole bunch of Japanese games
plus "Clash of Clans."
But even in the
case of Supercell,
while they've had
some success in Japan
relative to some of the other
markets where they've been in,
even for them it's
not easy to get there.
So it's something
where as attractive
as the Japanese market could
be, the Japanese developers
have set the bar very high.
And the Japanese
consumers have grown
accustomed to those games.
So it's important to be
very thoughtful in terms
of launching into Japan.
In terms of Korea-- so here,
historically, the Korean market
has focused on a bunch of
cute characters and animals
in its games largely through
the success of local developers.
However, that is
starting to change
with more and more international
games seeing success in Korea.
One example is Supercell
with "Clash of the Clans,"
where we could feel very
tangibly that whenever
"Clash of Clans" hit number one
top grossing in that market,
that it did start
to change perception
in an exciting way
about the opportunities
for international developers
to succeed the local market.
And it is actually
having an impact
on some of the strategies
and tactics of how developers
promote their games
in Korea where there's
a lot more TV and out-of-home
advertising that's
taking place.
And it's influencing a
greater number of developers
to have bigger
campaigns themselves
in this local market.
Next we'll focus on Taiwan.
Taiwan, if you'll notice here,
there's a great diversity--
again, similar to the
US-- where there's
Japanese games, Korean
games, local Taiwanese games,
Western games, Chinese games.
There's a lot that's here.
One funny characterization
too has been
Taiwan is the Canada of APAC.
And we say that as
a way for developers
that are looking to
beta test their games,
it's a great first landing spot.
If you're looking to
target APAC overall,
Taiwan can be a great
test market for you
because, obviously, there's
a great diversity of content
that this audience
is interested in.
If you're looking to
acquire some of these users,
prices in Taiwan
are still cheaper
than many other markets.
And then finally in
this section, in Russia,
there definitely are some
differences in certain markets.
Russia is very characteristic
in terms of the games that
are played there.
And so you'll see
a greater focus
on hardcore games in Russia.
And so you do have "Hay
Day" here, but outside
of that, not much casual games.
In the top of the
charts in Russia--
a greater focus on some of
the best games that are there
domestically and in terms of
a "World of Tanks" and war
gaming.
But in general there's
some clear themes
towards more hardcore gaming
in markets like Russia.
And so if that's what
you make, that's great.
However, if that's not
your games are about,
then you may want
to look elsewhere.
So anyway, I really hope
that this was valuable to you
in terms of tips
for working with us
and the various recommendations
that we have across the life
cycle of your games in terms
of pre-launch-- in terms
of user acquisition-- in terms
of engagement and retention,
monetization, then
international.
And I really encourage
you guys to stick around
for the lightning talks,
which will happen very soon.
And just thank all of you all.
We'll be around through
the course of the day.
So I hope you enjoy the
Goggle Developers Day today.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]